you have a Yin or young hand issue so
you're going to
push on it okay see and then but he's
doing a
Coq projection so that's a clash and
what always what I'm seeing is I'm
watching you is your elbow collapses
here you see and you're so your elbows
here and you did the yin hand but see
how
awkward this hand is
some of you will try to keep pushing on
it but look how low his his center is
from what you did
you see so stay there where you are
he's pretty squatty right now in terms
not in terms of his head but where is
his Center in relationship to his face
of support by by the time this
Yin hand got there
he should be here
do you see that and so I would I want
you to not watch
the tessabaki but watch what you're
doing to his Center so you guys hear
look how squatty he is you see and then
you're like
so part of your
your young hand
is actually he pushes is to get out of
the way
not to push him down into his face he's
saying no
to let him past you to let him come off
of his face let him come off of his face
so you have to have the yin yield but
your Yin yield is going here
and it's mostly from him
pushing your yawn
so your body goes this way
and you start to move him
this way I'm going to ask you to uh
reference his shoulder
you see that so not not here
see that his shoulder is traveling in
space which it's gonna do when you go
here you see it's just you're making
sure that this hand is not keeping his
shoulder there but that it too is
assisting that his shoulders move see
and that will stop his sin his Center
won't be squatty
you see
his head his spine is stilted but his
Center barely moved because you kept it
in place now home
now you're going to pay attention to the
young shoulder it keeps moving with the
in hand
and that happens because this hand
first does
the uh our spiral doesn't go straight in
there is a little then around
just like this one actually goes first a
little in
a little in and then to the outward
always a little yin and yang a little
Yang oh
[Music]
foreign
okay let's try again
is there a point during the technique
where the yin arm is no longer doing
anything and then it's just all the yawn
arm
okay let me preface the answer with
there's different levels
and that is necessary okay
um we already know there's
at a minimum three components
to your training so remember the the
model that we use here is expedited
from
all those all that research and
experience I've done so for example in
other Maps
they might go there are three components
but the spiritual component actually has
uh 108 levels
you see I was like no no what's the
point of three then you see so I don't I
don't do that okay but
why did another culture go there's 108
because there's some utility to it you
see for for answers like this kind of
stuff so
um
but that doesn't mean you're ready for
level one dash 109 or 107. you see so
you stick where I have left most if you
work on that there there is just no way
that you can do kokudosa
with
squatting his uh center of gravity
there's just you're there you're you'll
be violating
uh either the energetic level or the
spiritual level and obviously the
physical level so there as much as you
reconcile those three components there's
no way that you can do it by squatting
his center of gravity that those are all
that's all wrong okay so the upaya that
I gave you is to keep this young
shoulder moving okay
the only way that Yong shoulder will not
move is when you are doing a young young
Clash then you're gonna hold you're
gonna hold that shoulder still you see
and now as he pushes and as I push it
just squats him squats me and there's no
way that's right okay
but in answering this question
um
the yin hand
is the ikey hand
and the IT hand
is going to adhere
do you understand so it's not
it's not that he pushes and I just yield
it's
there obviously is a yield in the way
that I he is not a yawn
and in the way that aiki is not a
contestation
but this push this is a non-contestation
too but this is not IQ okay just like he
goes to grab that's a non-contestation
but that's not Ike either that's just
getting out of the way okay
ikey is going to reconcile the young
value and the yin the yin value so that
we adhere we adhere you see there's a
there's a friction here and it's not on
any kind of hook or anything like that
you just match the yin value which is
Ever Changing as his body is falling and
he responds to falling all that matches
so at the end when you when you feel
this
there's definitely I'm not pulling
even though that's going in the same way
that he's going right he's going that
way and I pull in that way that's still
not I key
so as he comes around you're going to
see what I do is I'm not cutting out
here if you pay attention
I just kind of lay on top here
and I don't I neither push nor pull I
neither lift nor press
and then I start I've stuck on him do
you see
so I'm we're gonna I'm gonna take the
rest of you back to that shoulder and
then you can look for this this hand so
he's trying to cook you projection
I'm not healed and I'm here just resting
okay
come up these things
that you have it
foreign
so as I'm here I'm not
stressing his grip but it's in here I'm
match that give me on value and that
creates that adhesion that adhesion
so a lot of times depending on what they
do I can't get
to here
do you see but I I'm he's touching me
here so that's what I adhere to that
that part
but I'm not pressing down
that time my arm did it
at that time my arm got over the top
you see
and that's where the adhesion is
here
so you have to resist
uh the throwing of him
as you said initially you get greedy and
you're like oh yeah I got him you have
to resist that and you're just doing the
relationship
so
you do have a physical component and
I've asked you there but you also have
this energetic component
and when I do the energetic components
although the I key adhesion
is happening out here
the source of it is in my body
so his young energy
is going to go into my body
and I'm going to rotate it with the yin
energy coming from the ground
and that what I let back out is equal to
whatever is on this hand
so in my mind when I'm practicing I
don't do uh
the throne I am just doing
this 16
of those two energies and then one hand
has the projection
if one hand has the adhesion
foreign
since this one felt greedy
remember you mentioned that
you won't see
my deltoid
or my ball and socket joint being
utilized
it won't pull
okay and the other thing you can look
for is how relaxed
the Hat the hands actually are
is this all over here
[Music]
approach right so
um I did I may have used the word relax
at the end like notice how relaxed the
arms are and then and you know
I guess what I'm trying to say there is
notice that I'm getting the effect
without the uh the muscular uh
utilization of the arms
and hence the effect is energetic okay
but the word relax is misleading because
then we go like and that's not it okay
um
I the the cycling energy
[Music]
is what's holding the Integrity of the
of the shape okay not not this
all right
um
the the orientation of
that cycling energy is what does the
throw
it's it's I I understand at one level
there's a push full uh you know kind of
anatomical displacement of his line of
gravity outside his base of support but
uh you have to move past that
um so the first thing before we get to
the answer to your question if it's not
relaxed what is it is let's stay still
uh physical
and let's note that uh suareza
is training that
isolates out
the midfoot point on the bottom of your
foot and zeros in on the quad okay so
you don't want to uh stay here there's
going to be movement
in the quad
okay let's some of us uh let's just
that's all you're going to do so I want
you to again I'm giving you a reference
point uh just like that's not kokudosa
but that's my reference point in whether
I had a young young Clash or not did the
shoulder keep moving diagonally forward
into the angle of disturbance okay so my
reference point here is the seams
between my legs and my pelvis I don't
want them to stay here in Cesar they
will move open and close Okay so as I'm
going to this way
they again because there's Yang and Yin
they're gonna open and close one way and
then open and close the other way okay
so if I would like for you to look at
the scenes that forget him forget my
hand work okay so you're gonna see
that if I throw that way first
first they go this way and then they go
that way okay so you're you're looking
for that whoa
oh
I I'm consciously
uh working that that's the whole point
of suareza okay
at if you're if you got that down
then what I want you to do
is take the time then and the tanden is
where it's
it's not a place
where that heaven
Chi and the Earth Chi meet
where they meet is the time death okay
so you're going to uh start to move that
tons in
and it is going to that energy is going
to go
out first with the quad so it's going to
rotate
this way
it's going to rotate up
that's what gets his Center up it's
going to rotate back the other way and
then down rotate forward
okay so I'm doing as I'm doing the
technique and he's pushing I'm going
it's going to rotate out
it's going to rotate up it's going to
rotate in and then rotate down that
energy so home
[Music]
you there's
and so you can't inverse it first move
your quad then then move your energy the
same way there's no way you can
reconcile the young John Clash without
that shoulder coming forward okay but it
doesn't mean you're doing everything but
that has to be there so as I'm doing the
technique I that those three or four of
you in the dojo you're gonna work on
feeling those
and you're gonna rotate it that's what's
rotating okay
for others you're gonna actually work
the seams of your legs
you're not gonna stay still and do the
technique
the seams move
foreign
no thinking don't think anymore just go
so I showed those two things because uh
to answer the question is it is it
relaxing no no it's not I I'm doing that
same thing that she is just circulating
again people will go like well you're at
an angle and they can't yes they they
freaking cancel I'll take it into my
shoulders then you're gonna see no
[Music]
they can push it any angle they want
they push they're going to push if I'm
not doing this
so these energies are circulating in me
allows my arms to be not using tension
to hold the spot but release and then I
rotate
[Music]
foreign
so when we go standing
now I've brought back to midfoot
and he will have a lot more power
because he can have his legs in there
okay so
our our next drill is
don't move your feet
who
foreign
still has to function for those that can
your Chi is still rotating
turning and then spinning down
foreign
[Music]
what we're demonstrating he's pushing is
that I can root that's all we're
demonstrating so when I when I go on one
leg it's not that uh I'm trying to not
hold them still or or whatever I'm
trying I would ever do a technique like
this but this demonstrates the rooting
skill that's all that demonstrates so
when I do my throw I'm not using
momentum and getting it out of the way
this young energy comes into my body
the rooting skill is the earth Qi the
yinchi that's going to now come up my
body and they circulate in my content
and that is what makes Aikido
so that's all I'm doing again that
that's all I'm doing again
moving
foreign
[Music]
circulating
and at the end it has to circulate down
in the drill
it doesn't go up
circulates down
[Music]
down
not down here down here
[Music]
okay try it again but this time I'll
move the the uh Tom Den all in place
foreign
[Music]
external Circle
nor do I have to have my ear get turned
himself
this turns turns him
foreign
movement going back like a few steps
so to have the left hand be the yin hand
okay
the claw goes this way
which means the
Yang and yinchi are going to turn
this way
so it turns then it's going to go back
okay so I it's going to come up
that's where he gets the lift you see
and now
it's gonna turn this way
this way
and then it's going to turn down
so it's going to go out up in down
out or to my right up in down that's how
you get it this is going to be the yin
hand that's how you're doing it here out
up in down
huh
I'm not here there's no movement you see
I move my body externally
or he comes forward and turns himself
around that's
I'm going to move I'm going to move him
oh I'm gonna move him I'm moving him
over there I'm moving them up I'm gonna
move him in you see I'm gonna move him
down I'm doing I do it all inside pop
okay try it again